there are many fair criticisms of Donald
Trump's first Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson I made many of those
criticisms when he was selected and when
he was the Secretary of State one would
be Tillerson is a tool of the fossil
fuel industrial complex undeniable
another is that Tillerson had a
disturbingly cozy relationship with
Russian oligarchs through his work as
CEO of ExxonMobil absolutely fair
criticism Tillerson lacked diplomatic
experience absolutely true although he
still was way more of a diplomat than
Donald Trump can ever hope to be a
tiller syns policies his politics are
way too conservative for my tastes all
of that stuff is true all of those
criticisms are more than 100% accurate
and we've made them on the program
before but until ursins sort of defense
he did more or less realize the
boundaries of his position and the
boundaries of legality and ultimately he
also became kind of unaligned with the
Trump doctrine and he ended up leaving
being insulted by Trump the usual fiasco
we know that Tillerson doesn't think
super highly of Donald Trump he was
caught calling him [ __ ] I think it was
asked about it didn't deny it so he
clearly doesn't have the highest opinion
of Trump but I have some interesting
video from a recent interview that
Tillerson did with CBS's Bob Schieffer
and he made it very clear what he
thought of Trump again being the
diplomatic guy that he sort of is check
out a little bit of the video and then
I'll tell you the really stunning part
of this do describe Donald Trump well
most of you probably know know some of
this but I had never met Donald Trump
until the day he asked me to be
Secretary of State he acts on his
instincts in some respects that looks
like impulsiveness but it's not his
intent to act on impulse I think he
really is trying to act on his in
stangs was challenging for me coming
from the disciplined highly
process-oriented Exxon Mobil Corporation
to go to work for a man who is pretty
undisciplined doesn't doesn't like to
read doesn't read briefing reports
doesn't doesn't like to get into the
details of a lot of things but rather
just kind of says look this is what I
believe so you get the idea of where
this is going and then Tillerson dropped
the bombshell the most key thing that
Tillerson said during this interview is
that Donald Trump would regularly direct
Rex Tillerson to do things that are
illegal okay he said quote so often the
president would say here's what I want
to do and here's how I want to do it and
I would have to say to him mr. president
I understand what you want to do but you
can't do it that way it violates the law
so understand the picture that we are
now able to build Michael Cohen's
sentencing memo from federal prosecutors
on Friday as I told you earlier says
Donald Trump directed Michael Cohen to
commit felonies this is part of a
federal sentencing document at this
point Rex Tillerson is saying Donald
Trump told me to do things that are
illegal Tillerson in contrast to Michael
Cohen apparently didn't do those things
this is what Trump does we now are
hearing from totally unrelated sources
Michael Cohen via federal sentencing
memo his personal attorney formerly and
then Donald Trump's Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson they're saying the same
thing which is Trump directs people who
work for him to do things that are
illegal Trump responding obviously by
insulting Rex Tillerson on Twitter
saying Mike Pompeo is doing a great job
I'm very proud of him his predecessor
Rex Tillerson didn't have the mental
capacity needed he was dumb as a rock
and I couldn't get rid of him fast
enough he was lazy as hell now it is a
whole new ball game great spirit at
state in retrospect Pat wasn't Tillerson
getting out when he did sort of a
brilliant move I think so this is all
very hilarious they have the president
calling
former Secretary of State all of these
words I guess the most generous
explanation to all of this is that Trump
just didn't know any better like he
didn't know that the way he wanted to do
things would be violating the law and
then once Tillerson responded by saying
that no you can actually do this this
way this is illegal he recanted he
decided to go some other path but we
don't that's not really in his character
that's not how this thing happened I
also tend to just disagree with Trump's
characterization that Pompeo is much
more mentally able than Rex Tillerson
from what I've seen that doesn't
actually appear to be the case the next
step however them the most important
thing here is we need to find out what
illegal things Donald Trump directed Rex
Tillerson to do right I spoke to a law
school professor over the weekend and
asked her can Rex Tillerson statement in
this interview that Trump directed him
to do illegal things can that be used to
justify molars team calling Rex
Tillerson in to talk to them she said oh
I'd be shocked if molar hasn't already
spoken to Rex Tillerson absolutely this
would justify speaking to Rex Tillerson
about what he knows it's going to be a
sprint until the end of the year I'm
locked in and ready to watch